[Musique]
j'ai des grandes aspirations gdg des
grands réel pour ces jeux l'eau puis
honnêtement je le dis que je reviens
avec l'art les choses ont le mérite
d'être clair mais surtout cette
affirmation est réaliste à 28 ans
marianne st gelais atteint une maturité
physique et psychologique et elle
s'améliore encore
[Applaudissements]
2016 elle a remporté son premier titre
de championne du monde une médaille d'or
qui est venu consolider son estime
personnelle
ambiance et l'eau je sais que je peux
rivaliser contre les meilleurs je suis
vraiment que tout ce que j'ai fait dans
les années qui ont précédé vont faire en
sorte que je vais être complète avions
de chasse
tout ça rend vraiment la jolie excitante
vous sent même temps parce qu'on dirait
que je lui ai déjà dit que je l'aimais
d'abord montré qu'un lot je le crois
jusqu'à maintenant mais rien a remporté
trois médailles d'argent aux jeux
olympiques de relais et une au 500 m à
vancouver
mais il ya quatre ans les jeux de sotchi
ont été très pénibles pour l'équipe
canadienne de patinage de vitesse courte
piste
il ya eu plusieurs shoots foot de
marianne violet l'ariana participer
aucune finale individuelle
il y avait énormément de frustration
mais tout le monde a appris de cette
déconvenue et marianne n'a pas eu peur
de se remettre en question pour
maximiser la fin de sa carrière
et cette fois ci elle aborde les jus
d'une manière toute nouvelle puisqu'elle
a déjà annoncé depuis belle lurette qu à
pyongyang
elle participera à ces derniers jours je
la vois comme un ultimatum je me dis
c'est ta dernière chance c'est que
laisse rien au hasard parce que y'en
aura plus de chance j'ai encore
l'énergie encore la fougue mais j'ai
aussi l'expérience que j'ai juste
l'impression que toutes mes cartes
les étoiles sont alignées pour ce jeu
marie josée turcotte radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'elle est